now back to our breaking news today
australia says it's revoking the visa
granted to tennis star novak djokovic
the country's immigration minister
exercised his discretionary power after
it emerged that djokovic who's
unvaccinated made a false claim on his
visa form in order to play in the
australian open a court blocked the
government's first attempt to revoke the
visa on a technical
ground djokovic now faces deportation
well tennis journalist steve pearce has
been following this all along and joins
us now from melbourne steve another
stunning twist in this saga what more do
we know about the grounds for the
decision to cancel djokovic's visa
yeah well it uh it is a twist isn't it
that we've been waiting for for quite a
few days now since djokovic had that
first win in the courts more on
procedural grounds a few days ago and
it's just it came through in the last
hour that um alex hawk the minnesota
citizenship has finally decided that to
cancel the visa and on the basis was in
the public interest to do so
um on health and good order grounds but
really what that means is on the basis
of
probably two factors firstly
on the grounds that
the recent infection of covet 19 as has
been
represented by novak djokovic the
federal government never never
considered that reason to be able to
come into australia unvaccinated and
secondly they do have this uh a second
reason to cancel a visa i don't think
they would cancel it just on these
grounds at all that uh he he filled out
his papers incorrectly on coming into
the country since apologize for that but
i don't think that alone would be
grounds for cancelling the visa but we
haven't had the exacts of the decision
yet um but it seems as if the federal
government is comfortable that it will
have a very very strong case should
novak djokovic is legal team as they
have indicated that they would challenge
this as soon as this decision came
through but it literally came through in
the last hour so it's unclear at this
stage what uh what what the next um
event will be in this long running saga
okay but the australian open tennis
tournament is still scheduled to
continue does this end djokovic's hopes
of defending his title there how long
could this drag on for
so i i wouldn't think it it ends it yet
it's certainly not um it's not what he
or his team would have been hoping for
or probably many people in serbia but
nevertheless it is also a move that was
not at all
unexpected um they would have been
preparing for this and i would assume
that they believe that they have a
fairly strong legal case for uh for
challenging this again in the courts
because the way that you know we've all
seen these images around the world of
djokovic practicing on rod laver arena
and his team looking confident and
comfortable and you can only assume that
they knew this was coming or they
suspected it was probably coming and
they have a a legal challenge ready to
go that will
allow him potentially to continue to
take his place in the draw but again as
it's been so often throughout this it
really is a 50 50. who knows what will
happen next
steve thank you so much that was tennis
journalist steve pearce there in
melbourne
you